Let's take our 2 equations and plot them on the same coordinate grid. Now that
we have 2 lines, we have a system of equations. We can represent the system
using 2 equations or graphically using 2 lines. This first line indicates that
you can spend $45 on the car rental, that's the most you're willing to pay. This
second line represents the cost of the car, notice that the line continues to
increase up into the right. This makes sense because the cost will continue to
increase if we rented the car for more hours. You pay 10 more dollars for each
hour you rent the car and that also is reflected on our graph. Knowing this
information, what's the longest amount of time you can rent the car. Write your
answer here.